I mean that's really what it is it's
it's an ideological battle and in that
sense veganism becomes very much like a
religion because you like you support
all the people that are on your side and
the people that are opposed to you or
like apostates they're like they're like
the negative people that are trying to
bring you to the dark side to hell it
gets it gets really crazy and there's a
lot of evidence on their side in terms
of like factory farming and their
horrors of factory farming and even the
the really incredibly poor modern
American diet that they see a lot of
people when they go vegan what they're
doing one of the best things that
they're doing is they're eliminating all
the [ __ ] they're eliminating all the
trans fats and all the [ __ ] all the
terrible [ __ ] that a lot of people eat
that isn't vegan yeah but the negative
thing is most of them are eating diets
that are far too carbohydrate rich and
if they're not getting their blood
checked they don't even know how
unhealthy they are they convince
themselves they're doing much better
than feeling much better but a lack of
cholesterol can [ __ ] with your hormone
functions a lot of vegans have low
hormones because of that we one of our
regulars at antler was talk to me about
about his experience he used to have a
organic vegetable farm and he's a six
foot seven big huge tall Dutch white guy
and he goes to me he says you know I was
vegan for a long time I had this organic
vegetable farm and I thought that I was
doing my body a service he said I
thought I was doing something great for
my body and he got really sick and he
went to the doctor and the doctor said
listen man you have to take supplements
just supplement the the things you're
not getting from from eating meat or you
have to go back to eating meat because
just some people's bodies do better than
others I said a lot of Asian cultures
are more susceptible to to vegetable
diets but he's like in reality he's like
you know you're your northern European
you know descent and you need to eat you
know this stuff to be healthy and that's
when he he went back to eating meat and
it doesn't matter you know what what
your truck he was living on an organic
vegetable farm like what what more
healthy you know vegetables could he be
eating so yeah b12 is a big one and b12
essentially only comes
things other than vegetables you can get
some of it from algae you can get I mean
you definitely can get it from meat it's
rich in meat and the other thing is iron
iron you know people say well there's
iron and vegetables there is but it's
not very bioavailable right a lot of the
various vitamins and even protein in
vegetables not very bioavailable in most
source and it's how your body absorbs
those nutrients as well like it might it
might be rich in that that that
substance but your body can't really
absorb it well it's just everybody's
body's different I mean it's just that
is an absolute fact that there's some
people that can eat certain diets and be
very healthy and then other people eat
them and they have a really hard time
with them
yeah but the other thing is that most of
these people that are talking about how
healthy and how great they feel there's
a lot of it is sort of a placebo effect
and they're not getting blood work done
yeah everyone regardless of what your
diet is you should get blood work done
just to find out if you have any
potential problems that are on the
horizon because there's a lot of times
you'll feel ok and then you get your
blood work done that the doctor will
tell you him and you're really low in
vitamin B and D and a and you know you
need this and that and you know this is
the health consequences of not having
this stuff in your diet and if you are
committed to a vegan diet there's ways
that you can supplement and this is my
advice to people if you want a
supplement
first of all algae is a great one you
know it tastes like [ __ ] but it's very
good for your body and you just add it
to smoothies you know just add it with
coconut milk or a bunch of other things
you can do it I mean you definitely can
eat a vegan diet and be healthy but you
got to be on the ball you know and the
the b12 one is a big one it's a a
massive amounts I was reading some crazy
article the other day said something
like 90% of all vegans are b12 deficient
I've heard this it's terrible um there's
a guy named Chris crecer that I had on
my podcast before who's a brilliant guy
who is he's an expert in diet nutrition
who started out as a macrobiotic vegan
and had massive health problems and then
switched to eating meat eventually and
then really became a con
sewer of organ meat which is like
probably the most nutrient-dense food in
the world I love I love that's my
favorite thing about hunting is the
organ meat lead tomb and I love liver
liver and the heart I I went hunting and
I came back and I brought the heart into
the restaurant for the guys I wanted to
you know share with them like the
experience of eating like fresh killed
like the heart was still warm when I
brought it to work and I the way I like
to use either tartare like just mince it
up raw or cook it like a steak so I cut
it you know horizontally and into like
it looks like a tenderloin steak and we
all got like this like buzz like we just
like shot a double espresso or something
it was just like whoa and it's like it's
so nutrient-rich the organ meat